Carrusel de las artes
María Carolina piña
[Música]
Carrusel de las artes sigue en el
Festival Internacional de Cine de Canes
Así que quédense con nosotros Porque ya
mismo le contamos lo más destacado de
esta cita con El séptimo arte mundial
luces cámara acción
[Música]
en estos momentos la capital del cine
grandes firmas de la pantalla grande
pasaron por la alfombra roja y en
especial una constelación de estrellas
de Hollywood el festival abrió una vez
más los brazos al mexicano amate
Escalante quien presentó perdidos en la
noche su último largometraje cinta que
aborda la compleja situación de México
Pedro almodóvar electrizó al público con
un cortometraje de vaqueros enamorados y
el argentino Lisandro Alonso puso de
relieve a los pueblos amerindios en una
ficción protagonizada por Kiara mas
troyani y nos fuimos de paseo al cine de
la playa en cannes que cada noche
Presenta una perla cinematográfica a
cielo abierto
[Música]
el festival de canesú Maya 76 años de
amor con el cine mundial de autor hemos
tenido algunos días de lluvia pero
también lluvia de estrellas sobre la
alfombra roja lo que desató el furor de
fotógrafos Y Amantes del cine
[Música]
fue una sucursal de Hollywood durante el
Festival Internacional de Cine con
derroche de estrellas planetarias que
desfilaron por la alfombra roja Martin
scorsese vino con dos actores de lujo
Robert de Niro y Leonardo DiCaprio para
el estreno internacional de Killers of
the Flower Moon una cinta impresionante
proyectada fuera de la competencia
la cinta de tres horas y media de
duración está basada en hechos reales la
masacre de la tribu osayo hace un siglo
en Oklahoma un ejercicio de memoria
histórica de la mano del Gran scorsese
contra fondo de riqueza petrolera y
drama romántico que Recuerda la deuda de
la sociedad estadounidense con sus
pueblos originarios
la alfombra roja de cannes llegó a su
punto de ebullición con la presencia del
inigualable Harrison Ford protagonista
del quinto Indiana Jones proyectado
también fuera de la competencia
el actor fue ovacionado por el público y
luego recibió una palma de oro de honor
por sorpresa un homenaje del festival de
cannes para esta figura legendaria que
ha marcado con Su carisma la historia
del cine
Estoy muy emocionado cuando estás en el
ocaso ves tu vida desfilar Acabo de ver
mi vida brillar y luego mis ojos estoy
profundamente emocionado y honrado pero
ahora tenemos una película que ver así
que me retiro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
del lado de las Divas Julian Moore y
Nataly portman posaron para los
fotógrafos en el estreno de made them de
todds una cinta sobre el mundo del
espectáculo West Anderson también trae
acá en su lote de estrellas con
asteroide City Tom hanks Scarlett
Johansson y Margot Robinson algunas de
las figuras protagónicas de esta fábula
de ciencia ficción
[Música]
México está en la selección oficial de
cannes 2023 con la última producción de
amat Escalante el director mexicano es
un invitado frecuente de este festival
con su obra anclada en la realidad y los
temas sociales perdidos en la noche no
es la excepción
se aparecieron a mi mamá Palma flores
Emiliano es un muchacho de 20 años que
busca los responsables de la
desaparición de su madre una mujer que
militaba contra la instalación de una
Mina en un territorio rural su
investigación lo lleva hacia los Aldama
una familia de celebridades excéntricas
Esa es la trama de perdidos en la noche
quinto largometraje del mexicano amate
Escalante un invitado frecuente de Canes
que en abordan sus películas la compleja
realidad de su país esta vez Escalante
filmó en Guanajuato su estado natal todo
apunta aquí
hay muchas desapariciones
forzosas que de activistas no eh Muchas
son mujeres activistas que que
desaparecen en circunstancias muy obvias
también Y es frustrante que a veces
simplemente así se queda la cosa no y en
muchos casos es gente que lucha contra
algo que luego
desaparece la persona y sigue ese
proyecto
Guanajuato es un estado minero no una
ciudad minera de hace más de 300 años
así empezó está esa tradición y
Guanajuato también ahora mismo es un
estado con mucho conflicto el más
violento ahora hoy en día y ahí vivo yo
y ahí me inspiro no Y también es uno de
los de las ciudades más hermosas de
México
como muchos en México Emiliano se
convierte en Buscador de su madre
desaparecida y en ese proceso conoce a
Mónica Aldama una chica que se hizo
famosa en redes simulando su propia
muerte el contraste es total entre estos
dos personajes interpretados por Esther
Expósito y Juan Daniel García Treviño
Mónica así es es muy creativa muy
particular y y se expresa a través de de
las redes sociales pero desde un lugar
es verdad muy morboso y
un poco oscuro por otro lado es aún
tiene esa niña con ganas de jugar No yo
me la imagino que que al final todo para
ella es un juego que le gusta jugar con
la gente y con y con la muerte y con
todas estas cosas a investigar bastantes
acerca de los buscadores No yo no tenía
esa experiencia ni estaba como tan
metido no pero este pero conocía
historias no este y se escuchan todo el
tiempo no también vengo como yo vengo de
un barrio no este que está eso todo el
tiempo no eso es lo que sucede no y es y
es muy real
perdidos en la noche fue proyectada en
la sección una cierta mirada del
festival de cannes
tú mismo lo dices siempre
el festival de cannes presenta durante
12 días más de 60 películas aquí vimos
por ejemplo a Pedro almodóvar huelín
clasificable Lisandro Alonso quienes
vinieron a Canes a estrenar sus más
recientes trabajos
entró a la sala bajo una lluvia de
aplausos Pedro almodóvar vino en persona
para presentar y comentar su último opus
un cortometraje titulado extraña forma
de vida el romance entre dos vaqueros
estadounidenses
[Música]
con Pedro Pascal
la cinta cuenta del reencuentro de dos
ex amantes tras un crimen que involucra
a sus familiares un corto sobre el deseo
el recuerdo y la belleza de la juventud
masculina
[Aplausos]
eureka es la nueva experiencia
cinematográfica del argentino Lisandro
Alonso una cinta de dos horas y media de
duración que navega en tres épocas y que
aborda la condición indígena de
diferentes tribus del continente
americano Lisandro Alonso nos explicó el
objetivo de esta película Sin trama
precisa sea la excusa de realizar una
película que me pongo en contacto con
gente que vive un poquito más a las
orillas de lo que conocemos o lo que
vemos todos los días la película camina
de un lugar para el otro y hay que
dejarse llevar digamos sin buscarle
muchas explicación me gusta más
compararla Quizás más a una pintura que
a una película no que por ejemplo cuando
uno no se puede ir a un museo o puede
ver alguna pintura en la casa de algún
amigo No necesariamente entiende De qué
trata pero ve y puedo hacer conexiones
No y sin juzgar no porque porque eligió
el rojo el verde porque es abstracto
figurativo placer estético no no hay que
buscarle mucha mucha explicación si te
animas a y disfrutar sin tener que tener
algo a cambio al final de la película Me
parece que se puede disfrutar mejor
eureka comienza también como un Western
en blanco y negro luego salta a la época
actual en el elenco el actor vigortensen
y la italun francesa Kiara más troyani
se cansó
es una película dentro de otra la
primera parte es una ficción de vaqueros
y luego se da paso a una cinta de corte
más documental me gustó mucho la idea de
Lisandro de abordar un tema del que se
habla poco en Dakota por ejemplo
filmamos con un equipo muy reducido
tratando de respetar ese territorio de
ser pacientes y de que aceptaran nuestra
presencia eso tomó tiempo pero fue tan
distinto al cine que yo he hecho
eureka de Lisandro Alonso se estrenó en
la sección can't del festival de cannes
les proponemos ahora un paseo por el
cine de la playa una experiencia única
gratuita y a cielo abierto todas las
noches al borde del mar el reportaje de
Melissa barra
cuando se levanta el telón en las alas a
la misma hora se alza la pantalla en la
playa aquí en la cual Se asiste a
proyecciones y encuentros de la
selección oficial sin esmoquin y sin
invitación Selecta es responsable del
cine de la playa de cannes
formó el director del festival tuvo la
idea de crear un cine para ver películas
del festival que la playa sea una sala
oficial de cannes a la que todos puedan
acceder con o sin invitación no se les
pide nada la entrada Sencillamente deben
hacer parte de los primeros 800 en
llegar hoy el cine de la playa es
imperdible la gente que vive aquí me
pregunta cada año si habrá el
dispositivo algunos vienen todas las
noches los cineastas vienen a presentar
sus películas cuando es un estreno viene
Incluso el elenco en los últimos años
recibimos a John Travolta Clint Eastwood
Uma thurman y tarantino les complace
venir al cine de la playa
[Música]
aquí el público viene a descubrir o
redescubrir grandes monumentos del
patrimonio cinematográfico mundial como
Lety One
de Carlos saura
no tenemos acreditaciones ni entradas de
cine para esta noche entonces estamos
felices de poder ver Esta película nos
sumerge en el ambiente del festival
sabíamos de que había proyecciones al
aire libre pero esta es la primera vez
que venimos queremos pasar un buen rato
y el ambiente es muy agradable aquí en
la playa
no tuve la oportunidad de ver Cintas en
la sala del festival vine a Canes A
última hora para explorar todo lo que
ofrece todo el mundo habla de Ver
películas en la playa de la posibilidad
de ver cine más clásico era un plan que
quería probar
lo
[Música]
el cine de la playa cumple más de 20
años dos décadas de películas diarias
durante la quincena Bajo el cielo
nocturno de cannes
Gracias Melissa barra y el festival de
cannes incluyó este año una programación
musical vamos a terminar este Carrusel
de las artes con el concierto de la
francesa y gendrcel aquí en la siboku
[Música]